old Knights are skating through their  pre-season games now we know they don't  count but they are important because  this is the time we kind of work out  some of the new wrinkles maybe get an  idea who's going to be on the ice set  the lines up get in shape Logan Thompson  in net for the knights tonight Vegas  hosting the Avalanche boy this was an  avalanche an avalanche of goals for the  good guys he's been on Zach  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  oh yeah you heard Dave Gosher say score  seven times tonight the night skate off  with a 7-1 win and they got to be  feeling pretty good as they prepare for  the next preseason game that's coming up  Friday at The Fortress against San Jose  seven o'clock